a source close to Aretha Franklin Aretha
Franklin's family tells CBS News this
morning the legendary singer is very ill
Franklin who is 76 has battled health
problems for several years now
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
cbsn is in detroit where the queen of
seoul's hometown is now rallying around
her Vlad good morning this is very sad
news today good morning this is the
church where a star was born nearly six
decades ago Aretha Franklin's father was
a pastor here in fact this street in
front of me is named for him and she
grew up singing for the congregation she
continued to be involved with the church
even after she became a household name
and now New Bethel Baptist is coming
together for its beloved Aretha Aretha
Franklin discovered her legendary voice
here
at the New Bethel Baptist Church in
Detroit where her father was a minister
the wreath is not only my daughter
wreath it is just a stone sing
[Music]
you've been asked our music style change
her gospel roots stayed with her
phenomenal reads of the church wouldn't
still be here pastor Robert Smith jr.
says the New Bethel Baptist Church is
praying for Franklin after learning she
is seriously ill a source close to the
family told CBS News Monday that
Franklin is at home in hospice care she
had been battling health issues in
recent years celebrities and politicians
reacted to the news of Aretha 's poor
health Monday praying for the Queen of
Soul singer Mariah Carey tweeted Hilary
and I are thinking about Aretha Franklin
tonight President Bill Clinton wrote at
a concert in Detroit Monday night
Beyonce and jay-z dedicated their show
to Franklin
DJ Khaled opening for them paid tribute
to Franklin by getting the crowd to sing
respect even as Franklin's star rose she
never forgot where she came from just
weeks ago pastor Smith says she
contacted him about performing at the
Church's annual benefit concert asking
God to continue this miracle because is
great that she's made of this wrong
in 2017 detroit honored franklin by
naming the street after her many of
those attending the Beyonce concert last
night had to actually cross that Street
to get there here at New Bethel
parishioners will hold an early morning
vigil service for Franklin tomorrow
beyond the country in the world really
pulling for the Queen of Soul right what
an impact she's had prayer is all over
the world all over the countries and I
know that prayer works so let's hope
that this turns out in a very good way
you know she's a fighter yes she is yes
sure
definitely yeah